first question for you I want to know
what is your Ken's greatest asset at the
very beginning of the movie but I also
want to know what you think his greatest
weakness is the thing he needs to
overcome to become a better Ken oh
that's such a good question
um
yeah here's the thing okay I think I
think my Ken's greatest asset at the
beginning of the movie
is that um he can backflip
that's right I said it it's a spoiler uh
he could backflip he backflips really
well actually
um and it becomes uh surprisingly a big
plot point that that he can backflip um
because it makes Ryan's Ken really
really jealous it just irks him that
there's something that this can can do
that his can can't and
um and for my I mean as as Ken I love
that Ken loves that and um and I would
say that gives you a clue into Ken's
greatest weakness not just mine but I
think everyone's is that
um you know there is no there is no
sense of of community among the Ken's
there's a lot of infighting there's a
lot of uh a lot of tearing each other
down and when you're kind of starved for
that kind of sense of Ken Dome that's
this Brotherhood of Ken's
um I think it can it can lead you to be
you know pretty pretty miserable and
really competitive for no reason
um and then over the course of the movie
I would say with a couple of uh wrong
turns along the way a couple of
misguided things happen but uh I think
the Kens ultimately end up in a very
good place where they're able to
hopefully
um you know coexist harmoniously with
the Barbies all right I like I like the
sound of that for the future for for the
potential people
at the end of the day
today I'd say it was your Ken who had
gone to the real world what might of
Barbie land have turned into would it
have been the same as uh Ryan's Ken and
what he creates or would your Ken have
created you know a different song
different movie different vibe other
than you know cowboys and horses yeah
that's a really that's a really
interesting question
um yeah I think I think my Ken would
have some interesting uh design ideas
for a Barbie Dream House that maybe
Ryan's Ken would not have
um I find that I find the horse
symbolism very
um very interesting a little
questionable not really sure where the
fixation on horses come from I would
probably pick a different animal like a
wolf
um I would say you know more wolf
a lot of wolf
um nunchucks maybe I'm kind of feeling
like who doesn't love nunchucks
um
um I'd probably have like some you know
because I think my Ken would probably
stumble into you know Koreatown would
probably discover you know uh Boba for
the first time or like Korean barbecue
would just become really obsessed with
that so there'd be a lot of grilling
there'd be a lot of barbecues a lot of
backyard barbecues
um and
um what else what else would my Ken
bring back from The Real World
um
break dancing
I think my Ken would like you know
because because
you know all Ken's can dance but I think
if my Ken were to run into a break
dancer in the real world I think that
would just blow his mind and he would be
like I need to bring this back it's the
greatest thing ever
it's exactly how I felt when I first saw
breakdancing for the first time as long
as we get back to World Peace at the end
of this version of the movie like this
sounds like a fun a fun Barbie land Ken
Dome to come visit for a little bit
absolutely break dancing naturally I
think would segue quite nicely into
World Peace okay so you just brought up
that all Ken's can dance but I want to
know can all actors who are playing
Ken's dance who was the best dancer and
then who you know needed a little work
to get the choreography right oh oh man
look I can't name any names I can't name
any names all right all I want to say
all I want to say is that uh there's one
Ken in the movie who can uh who can uh
backflip and only one kid in the movie
backflip and this become this is a very
important point in the story of the
Ken's because uh makes all the Ken's
really really jealous okay so you were
you are at the top of the list I will
believe I mean I
everybody was really it was so fun doing
dance practice with every with all the
Kens which by the way is one of the
probably one of the favorite sentences
I've ever said out loud
um you know like everyone is so great
from like from oh my God Scott to shooty
Ryan of course
um you know Ryan I'm I know you've seen
the YouTube videos used to be quite a
dancer
um and still is I'm happy to report and
uh in Kingsley of course as well
um it was just so much fun with those
guys and we had incredible
choreographers
um in Lisa wellum Jen white they were
just the best and and um made it easy
for us to to pick it up all right I have
uh one more name I want to drop here to
sing her Praises a little Greta Gerwig
what is something unique about Greta as
an actor's director that you really
appreciated here something that made you
feel like you know you could even exceed
your own expectations for your work in
this film yeah that's a that's a really
really great way to put it I think Greta
comes from such a I mean to you know she
comes from such a love of you know
Cinema such a love of like you know
theater old school theater
um I think she she really placed a lot
of importance on the rehearsal process
and that's important we don't always get
that in in the film world and just
getting to you know getting to put
scenes on their feet before you know we
saw any of the sets but just kind of
actor to actor getting a play getting to
sense each other's energy getting
getting a sense of like where we were at
and I thought that was so crucial and
um it was in one of my first you know
rehearsals with Ryan that I was so blown
away by his tenacity by his talent and
it was it was a very important moment
for me because I was like oh thank
goodness I didn't witness this for the
first time as the cameras were about to
roll because I got to really up my game
like he was incredible and um I just uh
it taught me so much and and
that among many other things I think is
why Greta is just such an amazing
director and the perfect director for
this movie do not forget you can
backflip you never have to feel the
pressure that's true that's true I did
yes yeah I must leave you but I will say
congratulations on Barbie and thank you
for your time today
thank you so much